two days after sacking 800 staff without
notice piano ferries has restarted its
service from liverpool to dublin the
dubai owned firm says the ship which is
understood to have a crew not affected
by the sackings has resumed a normal
service
elsewhere the company's ferries are
still tied up as the political fallout
continues over thursday's move to save
money by firing directly employed crews
and replacing them with cheaper agency
workers
one of the agency workers filmed as he
was driven into cairn ryan in scotland
to replace the crew of the european
highlander
he shared pictures he took of security
staff they met in a car park on the way
here's 10 guys big boys you know good
front rowers
handcuffs
and balaclavas type hats and black masks
and i thought what's going on here he
claimed he was lied to about the job and
told me he walked away when he learned
about the sacking
we're going to be taking their jobs
and they're also i think so
and then that just it clicked with me
ministers seemed unsure what can be done
despite universal condemnation
it's this kind of sharp practice that
that has so uh
both the employees the british public at
large and the government but being no
doubt that the government stands ready
to take that robust action we're
establishing exactly the facts of what
they have done and determining
appropriate action
here on the humber the pride of hull has
not moved since thursday pno ferry says
it is halving its crewing costs and the
800 staff are being promptly and
properly compensated
it's not known how long it will be
before the ferries with new agency crews
will be given clearance to sail
gerard tub sky news hull